هل من تطورات فيما يتعلق بهذه الوقفه
الاحتجاجيه التي تخللها التدافع ما بين
اهالي ضحايا انفجار مرفا بيروت والقوه
الامنيه امام قصر العدل في بيروت
[موسيقى]
لقضيه اهالي ضحايا انفجار بيروت المطالبات
بطبيعه الحال تركز وتشدد على ضروره
استكمال هذا المسار ولكن فلنعت قليلا الى
ما جرى بدايه نشاهد الكاميرا عشرات
المتظاهرين كان من اهالي الضحايا او مينا
الناشطين اللبنانيين قبل قليل تم اعتقال
احد همم
الى همم الى الداخل لم نعرف مصيره قبل
دقائق من الان وبطبيعه الحال نحن نترقى
قرار مجلس الاعلى القضاء اللبناني الذي من
المفترض ان يعقد جلسه بعد قليل لحسم مصير
القاضي طارق البيطار قاضي التحقيق في قضيه
انفجار مرفا بيروت
[موسيقى]
من امام قصر العدل في بيروت